you've been complaining that there are a
lot of would you say Asian guys out
there who claim to be mistaken for you
yeah hey that's a common it's at a
complaint for me it's okay so sometimes
people will come up to me and they won't
know if I am so though they won't really
ask but then if they do ask I typically
don't want to lie and say I'm not
because I want to once and for all be
like yes you're right the one Asian guy
you recognize is the Asian guy the
actual Asian guy don't all look the same
but like you get now people you have
people that send you pictures that say
I'm tired of like getting mistaken for
yeah but it doesn't even make sense yeah
like the one I think we have a picture
here of yeah
I have to say I don't know how you look
like you you have to say he doesn't look
like me at all nothing like he can't go
out in public the mall trying to shop
and yeah bothering him it's wild people
will come up in like I get mistaken for
you all the time and I'm like you're 55
years old
I'm like or you're like a 12 year old
girl what do you it's like once and for
all
we don't all look alike that's what I'm
here to tell now you have found that
what you claim to be pictures of
look-alikes of famous is this you
brought something yeah yeah it likes
plain what this is I I am I am a
redditor I scour the reddits
okay yeah but what's funny is like in my
mission to also show that all Asians
don't look like I'm using the other
tactic which is that we all look alike
so I've there's this guy's message unit
yeah I know
I mean like I don't know what I'm doing
really well you're at the right place I
found this guy on the internet it's an
Asian a Brad Pitt you found there oh wow
it's uncanny he is for his Brad Pitt
yeah so if all Asians look alike then
Brad Pitt's Asian yeah you'll take that
sure and you found someone else you
found someone who looks like the black
Damon that one's pretty good can't tell
which is which
I was really good so confused right now
well that's probably cuz Matt Damon's
already pretty black and then what was
the last one you found I found an Asian
Elijah Wood yeah
[Laughter]
you